the Arctic was for centuries largely
unknown a very remote part of the
Western world and it was only 100 years
ago that discoverers starting to go to
the North Pole and to these remote areas
and then the cold war closed the Arctic
in terms of military confrontation and
the conflicts between the Soviet Union
on one hand and the Western powers on
the other so one of the most important
things to remember when we look at the
Arctic in the beginning of the 21st
century is that it is so recently that
we as mankind have been able to come
together to discuss and decide what do
we do with respect to the Arctic future
there is no part of planet Earth which
has so recently arrived on our desk as a
challenge and as an opportunity
so therefore the cooperation in the
Arctic is one of the most crucial issues
of the 21st century for many reasons one
is that this is the frontline of climate
change the aggressive melting of the ice
in the Arctic will have consequences all
over the world if only a quarter of the
Greenland ice sheet melts this will lead
to two meters rising sea levels
everywhere in the world and already we
are seeing that the present melting of
the Arctic sea ice is causing extreme
weather events in the United States in
Asia and in other parts of the world in
addition the Arctic is one of the
richest parts of the world in terms of
untapped natural resources and with the
continuous melting of the Arctic sea ice
there will be a new shipping line
linking Asia to America and Europe in a
revolutionary way like the Suez Canal
and the Panama Canal did in its time
that is why the Arctic has now become
the new economic and political playing
field in 2015 the United States takes on
the chairmanship of the Arctic Council
it is the first time since the Arctic
Council became a treaty making
organization that the u.s. takes on that
responsibility and the chairmanship is
not just a formal role it is supposed to
provide a vision a policy agenda and the
direction towards the future so it
seemed very important that all the
people in the United States who are
interested in climate change who are
interested in the environment realize
that in the next two or three years the
US will be in the leadership role with
respect to the future of the Arctic of
course in partnership with other article
trees as well as the observer States
from Asia and Europe although the Arctic
Council is an intergovernmental body
there is a role for activists
environmentalists
experts scientists ordinary people in
this process and in order to facilitate
that together with many other partners
on the Arctic I established last year
which called the Arctic Circle which is
a kind of international assembly where
everybody whether it's an individual or
citizen or or government or cooperation
or scientific Institute or university or
activist group can come together where
everybody has the same role the same
right to speak and undiscussed so I
would encourage especially the next two
or three years everybody who is
concerned about these issues in the
United States first of all to
look at the Arctic Circle on the website
Arctic Circle dot org and see if you
want to come to the assembly if you want
to attend the forum meetings that will
take place in the United States in
Greenland and Singapore as well as
Iceland in the next 12 to 18 months but
I will all be aware that your own
country the United States of America
will from 2015 2017 be the leader in
making policy an agreement and map out
the future for that part of planet Earth
where climate change is most
aggressively taking place there was a
big great march in New York about
climate and hundreds and thousands of
people participated I'm not sure if many
of them realized that in the early
months of next year it will be the u.s.
who will cheer the International
Cooperation on that part of mother earth
where climate change is most
aggressively taking place